[Music]
hello everyone and today we're gonna be
talking about our studio server noir
studio server pro just to help give
everybody a sense of what the value
proposition is for our server broth so
let's start with just our studio server
and what it does the open source server
is a way for you to take the IDE that
you know and love for your desktop and
be able to bring it to the web browser
basically being able to move the
computation and and the RAM to a
centralized location so organizations
usually look at running our server when
when they want to provide their analyst
with great access to greater compute
than they otherwise would have been able
to get on other laptops or more RAM so
some organizations we've talked to can
you know have you know 16 32 64 cores
some cases even 100 cores and and in
some cases up to a terabyte of RAM so
obviously that's a lot more than what
you can get on a single laptop and the
other reason that people like to run the
server is for them to centralize
computation so for them best centralized
access to data so if they have large
data data clusters and whatnot this
allows them to do the analysis near the
near the data as opposed to having to
bring it back down to to the laptop and
and finally it's really convenient
because now you can access it from any
class device that has a web browser so
all the other the other benefit that we
that people leverage the server for is
to be able to constrain which version of
our and which version of that our
libraries their users can use those are
all the benefits of the open source art
studio server left hand side there you
see different user browsers that are
connecting again this could be ie
Firefox Chrome and you're talking the
server showing it a centralization of
access to the r-process
our environment
the pro edition is geared really towards
making it easier for the server to be
integrated within an enterprise
environment so there are a lot of
features and capabilities that are
useful for IT organizations to be able
to have comfort and adopting are so
there are better tools for management of
sessions and and resources as well as
metrics monitoring and and features
around high availability so we'll start
with the the administrative dashboard
and the first top left there you'll see
that we you know we give you a view into
the running server so you can see the
CPU usage the memory usage the load
average and historical view of the
sessions versus the memory versus CPU
utilization the load average and the
second region there we sort of show you
the list of users that have been using
the system at all you know over the last
thirty days you get to see their average
memory usage the amount of CPU and if
you wanted to you could dig in on any of
those users and and get a better feel
for what they've what they've done and
potentially what errors they've seen
finally you get a chance to see sort of
the running sessions right now so who's
active we have the server right this
minute you can do things like suspend
that the session if you have my
privileges you can sort of terminate
this at that session if you have the
right privileges or you can conceivably
take over that session if they had an
issue they had a problem that they need
help with next we have a whole bunch of
statistics that we're sort of capturing
to help help the IT person or whoever's
managing the server to get a feel for
what's going on the server so if there
are slowdowns that are occurring all of
the metrics that we show you here are
ones that you could configure to send
into your own system so that you can use
the existing tools and use existing
learning infrastructure that you have so
people are sort of tied these two
graphite or HP openview or whatever your
paper tool is and then finally on the on
the right hand side there there's a
quick way of searching the logs seeing
what errors are showing up being able to
slice and dice them in different ways so
that an IT person or